we are sure that ryan reynolds has some
pretty good traditions with blake lively
as well and their three daughters but as
it turns out ryan reveals he sometimes
gets mistaken
for an a-list star
yeah appearing on the podcast dear hank
and john ryan revealed he gets mistaken
for ben affleck at a pizza shop in new
york listen to this
hey brian there's a pizza place in the
east village of new york that that i've
been going to for years that they they
believe i'm ben affleck and i've never
corrected them
i mean yeah i have a few things like
that yeah if you don't do a good job of
correcting people immediately it becomes
a situation where you can never correct
oh you can't do it after that yeah i'm
kind of like yeah i feel like it would
be it would not go over well if i
you know revealed well and that's yeah
they've been telling their friends for
so long that ben affleck comes in all
the time and they're gonna have to like
like issue a correction yeah that's no
good and i and i don't i don't i also
don't also don't accept anything like
they're not giving me free pizza based
on this factory i yeah you do everything
normal like everybody else they just
think i'm ben affleck and you know
they'll ask how jlo is
great
that's where all of the us weekly news
comes from yeah they're yeah you're just
you're the you're the main source for
ben affleck related yeah us weekly news
incorrectly leaking information but i
think what i think makes it so
believable with them is that i look
mildly sort of put out like sure
they're asking me again like about my
life and the movies and i sort of look
like yeah they're like i don't get it
when they when i leave they just i think
they sort of think i don't think that's
amused by us
wait do we think he looks like ben uh uh
ben affleck i guess a little bit no
thanks a little bit yeah i
if you think all white people look alike
then possibly
he also gets compared to kate beckinsale
right yes compared to kate beckham ryan
reynolds compared to kate kate
beckinsale she talked about this in 2019
where they look very similar so ryan
seems even he gets ryan gosling as well
people get confused but i can see the
similarities there no i mean i kind of
do s videos is saying he actually saw
ryan in real life thought he was either
jake gyllenhaal or ryan gosling i get
the sense that people are like i know
who he is but maybe they can't recognize
like right away ben affleck kind of
i don't know they were asking for jlo
like they completely thought he was
they're so waiting for j.lo to come in
they're going to be disappointed however
if lively walks in they'll be very happy
yeah the beard is this with the mask or
beard yeah that seems like there's a
mask on and this is interesting
maybe i think it's more brain fog i
think it's like i know you're famous but
i can't quite put my finger on it and
you're naming all the guys that are in
this similar vein they all can kind of
play the same roles maybe
have beards are similar but they're not
the same have you ever been compared to
someone else have you ever been called
something someone else have you someone
said
two years at my old job security called
me megan for tears and i megan
who's megan
just i thought my name was megan and i
didn't correct them and it went on for
years and i felt i just felt so bad i
didn't want to embarrass them but i went
by megan for a long time what
oh my god
i've had like over the years like
especially my teen years when i would
like kind of try to go to a mall or a
theater and like people knew me in
canada or whatever people would come up
to me and say
did anybody ever tell you that you look
like keisha shantae
i always respond i swear i love that i
would always go i go yeah i've heard
that before and i would continue on my
day they'd have to ask them every like
wait are you keisha then i'll say yeah
but if there's something i've had people
do that i've had people do that to like
my mom and my family
you look like aaliyah though you have a
very similar face to aaliyah you do
when i was younger yes now i think that
i've like i don't know i don't know what
i've done lately things would change but
when i was younger yeah i used to get
that
nice
i love it you don't know what's happened
uh no definitely i could see that
yeah definitely people online are saying
no he doesn't really look like
ben affleck so there you go yeah this
all it's ridiculous i don't know guys
all right you know what i get all the
time what you look like my neighbor are
you are you my neighbor do you live
across from dorothy like people assume
that i'm someone that they get their
school function
or i get that a lot like do you know my
sister gwen like stuff like do you live
next to an old folks home because that
sounds real weird
listen i have a lot of beautiful senior
citizen neighbors who are amazing so
that does happen quite a bit yes
cynthia
i like it it's true just throwing an
accent